وهذه صور مشاهدينا خاصه
للعربيه من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كما
نشاهد واياكم هذه الصور وربما استمرار
لحالات
النزوع
والاجلاب من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
وكما نشاهد هذه الشاحنات التي تنقل عددا
من المواطنين ربما السودانيين من العاصمه
الخرطوم والحافلات ايضا كذلك الموجوده في
شوارع العاصمه الخرطوم قبل كنا نشاهد احدى
الحافلات وهي محمله
المحمله طبعا
بشنط على ظهر هذه الحافله ربما استعدادا
لمغادره العاصمه الخرطوم التي تشهد
اشتباكات متصاعده وتوتر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم منذ 11 يوما بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اذا ربما هذه
الصور تصف الحاله الموجوده في الخرطوم
اليوم بمغادره العاصمه التي تعيش حاله من
عدم الاستقرار وعدم اليقين لدى المواطنين
السودانيين من القادم وربما ايضا تصاعد
وتيره الاشتباكات هو ما يحفزهم على الخروج
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وذلك ايضا
بعد ان اجلت البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والسفارات والقنصليات ايضا الموجوده في
الخرطوم
مواطنيها والعاملين ايضا كذلك فيها الى
خارج السودان عبر
رحلات بريه
وطبعا بريه الى الحدود ودول المجاوره
للسودان وكذلك الى ميناء بورتودان وبعد
ذلك نقلهم الى دول مجاوره كالمملكه
العربيه السعوديه او ايضا اجلؤهم عبر
طائرات عسكريه من السودان
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات